we are now live stream as i can
see yes we are thank you
welcome to rochefort district council's
remote statutory officer personnel
committee meeting
and welcome to anyone who is watching
via this live stream
item one apologies for absence
my understanding is there have been no
apologies received
in the office item two
substitute members attending
no substitutes have been notified to the
office
item three non-members attending
non-members will be able to access the
public part of this meeting via the live
stream
item four to receive declarations of
interest are there any members who wish
to declare an interest
can't see no thank you members
the gender item 5 is the statutory
committee's training in the role of the
committee we have with us this afternoon
david kitson from bevin britain welcome
david
who will guide us through the relevant
training issues
uh questions will be answered at the end
of this by david if if there are any or
other officers as
as appropriate um over to you david
thank you chair um good afternoon
everybody um so you've all uh had a
chance to read through the report so i
won't read it verbatim
um unless you want me to of course um
but yeah this is uh in essence an
overview of because this is a as you've
heard a brand new committee of the
council it's something
that the council is required to have by
law and
through chief officer terms of
conditions of service as well so that's
why the council has set this committee
up
so there are processes that have to be
followed
in relation to business being dealt with
by the committee
and so i'm going to try and give you an
overview of that
and of course i'm happy to to answer any
questions um that you may have
at the end of the presentation so as i
say
the the council has to have um a
committee of this nature to deal with
uh chief officer discipline if you like
um the there are regulations
and there are also uh these as i
mentioned joint negotiating committee
terms and conditions of service which
are set out in a handbook
now those the joint negotiating
committee is a joint committee between
the lga
and alice which represents chief
executives
and they have jointly negotiated
appropriate terms and conditions for
chief officers chief executives
that are incorporated into those
officers
contracts um so
together they well the regulations
themselves uh
the leader david could i just stop you
there
um christine you have your hand up you
wanted to ask a question at this point
yeah i just wanted some clarification
um i i read through this report
this morning and i've got no issue with
the report
for information sonia i haven't got your
email i haven't had any emails for
council today
um but i've read it online
um the report
it says this for the
uh the three senior officers the
monitoring office of the finance officer
head of
paid service which plan is
obvious in some ways however
and there's no disrespect meant here
angela
it's the reports written by one of the
officers that it
um it affects
monitoring officer so i just wondered if
that had been validated
but externally because there's obviously
a potential
conflict there now i don't know if i'm
right and i don't know if i'm wrong
but it just flagged up as a general
concern
so before we go into the detail i just
wanted to
know that that was okay
would you like me to to respond okay
through you chair um yeah valid points
yes the report
is in the name of the monitoring officer
as you say the
um the committee concerns those three
officers so the
um head of paid service monitoring
officer in section 151 this isn't about
specific issues this isn't about
specific matters
um what the council has to have in place
is
very much prescribed if you like by what
the regulations say and
and what the jnc uh terms uh
and conditions of service are so this is
simply
if you like um well as it sounds it's a
training session it's an overview of how
these things might work moving forward
if they were ever necessary
um because it's a new committee it's
important that you understand that
where where the basis of these things
lies if you like so
albeit ultimately yes it could deal with
one of those three officers
that's not what we're dealing with here
this is this is about
this is a process you have to have in
place by law and by
uh the terms and conditions the jnc
terms and conditions so
i can see why you're concerned and and
thank you for raising that but it
chair it's not an issue of concern
in relation to this matter thank you
that's all i wanted was confirmation
that there was no
um issue there and apologies angelo is
certainly nothing personal
thank you councillor mason thank you
david you're welcome
if i can continue chair if that's if
that's okay
um yeah so um so the regulations provide
statutory protection to the chief
officers against dismissal
so what they say in essence is that
those chief officers cannot be dismissed
from their posts
without a resolution of full council
and as i say there is a process that has
to be in place
involving a committee of this nature
which would then
ultimately lead up to a matter being
taken to
full council for for determination so
i'll go through as i say it is quite a
complex
um procedure and process um
so i apologize in advance of that but
i'll try and set it out in a logical way
so the terms of reference for this
committee are
as we've mentioned they include dealing
with um
disciplinary issues in relation to chief
officers and that also includes
potentially dealing with
um settlements and severance agreements
relating to those
officers too so the first
step i suppose in terms of potential
dismissals or disciplinary in relation
to chief officers
is consideration whether engaging the
process with the committee is actually
necessary
so ordinarily what you have in place
is an initial consideration
often by an officer in consultation with
the chair of the committee
as to whether an allegation or complaint
against one of the chief officers
are whether they're clearly unfounded
trivial or whether they could be dealt
with through some
of the process so if they could then
they won't necessarily go through the
the committee process um
taking things too formal to the formal
process should really be a
last resort and that's in line with you
know statutory guidance
around these sorts of things as well
however if
if it's felt at that initial stage that
there may be something in this and it's
not uh
you know i say this the allegations it's
not clearly unfounded or trivial then
the matter will
be taken for what's what you would call
an initial fact-finding exercise that's
not an investigation
as you would understand an investigation
it is
what it sounds it's gathering initial
facts to enable
a decision to be made as to whether
there is
whether whether they're merit to further
investigation in essence
so what then happens is ordinarily
either an officer of the council
or an external consultant or
professional
can be engaged to to undertake this
initial fact-finding
process you know speak with the officer
against whom the allegations have been
made put them to them get their response
to that
and gather information that's relevant
to the allegations that have been made
what will then david sorry to interrupt
you again um
and another member wishes to ask a
question
would you like to continue through the
report first and then
seek questions later or take questions
as they arise
um is it is it a question that is you
know
can it wait if not it's fine i can i can
do it through the chair
it wasn't a question that you were
freezing you were you were actually
frozen a few a
few seconds right and it was hard to
understand you david that was what this
was
right so in case you had a problem with
your connection that was all it was
i did i
i don't think anyone else suffered that
but but would you rather wait for
questions later david
um yes yeah i think if we can take
questions at the end that might be
thank you members yeah thank you for
pointing that out uh counselor sure so
um so as i say the initial fact finding
will then be brought to yourselves
as the committee and it's not the point
at which
there will be a detailed uh
investigation or or
should i say not an investigation but um
presentation of evidence
you can hear from witnesses you can ask
questions ordinarily that doesn't happen
um and the officer against whom the
allegations
are made is also able to attend to put
their uh position forward at that stage
stage
so that first hearing of of your
of the committee meeting is to
to come to a decision whether what's
known as the threshold test
is met so in terms of the threshold test
what you are um doing is
is a looking at um
whether the alligator if the allegation
was proved
that's been made would that lead to the
dismissal or
or other action that would be recorded
on the chief officer's personnel file
and if so is there evidence to support
the allegation is it sufficient to
support the allegation
and therefore point towards there being
a need for
further investigation so you're not
making a decision at that point on
whether or not the allegations approved
or proven
at all what you're doing is forming that
initial view is there
is the is the allegation sufficiently
serious and
if so is there adequate information
on the basis of the uh uh fact finding
uh and the and the information put to
the committee at that time
um to suggest that it's necessary to go
to investigation
now at that point if if the committee
isn't
satisfied that that threshold test is
met
then they can either make the decision
or yourselves can either make the
decision
that there'd be no further action or
that there'd be an
unrecorded uh informal warning so
something short of being recorded on the
file in essence
if if the committee of the view that
if it was if the allegations were proven
it would warrant something being
recorded
on the file or a dismissal then and the
evidence
suggests that it needs to be looked at
then you go to a separate stage
so the next stage
if the committee believe that there is
that this threshold test is met
is to uh appoint an independent
investigator now what normally happens
there
is that contact will be made with the
jnc the joint
negotiating committee as that i
mentioned earlier
and they keep a list of independent
investigators
and it's done on a taxi rank basis if
you like
so what they do is they take the next
three
investigators in line and they put
forward the names of those
and cvs of those investigators
to the council um what then happens is
that
is that those three individuals that
list and the
and the uh cvs are then given to the
chief officer for them to make a
decision which of those three they
want to select to undertake the
investigation
if the chief officer or the statutory
officer
doesn't make a decision within 14 days
then it falls back to the council to
make a decision to appoint one of those
three
so once you have an investigator
appointed they will then undertake the
investigation
so they will go off they will gather
evidence
obviously you would set terms of
reference in terms of what they're
expected to
to cover off so they would work to those
terms of reference
they would interview all relevant
parties
gather all relevant information and then
they would write a report
now their report would then be brought
back to the committee
and in that report they would be
stating their opinion in terms of the
evidence is it
uh adequate to support the allegations
if not why not if it is why is it and
they will also be giving
a view and recommendations as to what
the appropriate action might be
so if they feel that the evidence
doesn't support it then
they might be making a recommendation
that there's no further action taken
um or that something short of uh
recommendation for dismissal perhaps um
is is contemplated
um so the hearing uh there will be a
hearing of course where that report's
presented as i've said
and witnesses will be called as will the
statutory officer be given opportunity
to come along
to question witnesses themselves um to
be
questioned um etc cetera so it's it's
kind of
um a sort of a quasi-judicial hearing if
you like
um so so all the evidence is is gathered
cross-examinations take place and then a
decision is made
by yourselves um what the outcome of
that should be
so i don't think well you will have read
the reports and and you'll have seen
reference to the um panel of independent
persons now that panel
is made up of the independent persons
who are appointed by the council for the
purposes of
the standards legislation
so the localism act now the
there are two ways that the process can
go so
the jnc guidance envisages that
there will if there is a recommendation
by the committee having heard the
evidence
that there should be a dismissal
that then goes to the independent panel
for them to consider and give their
views
now as you probably um would agree i
mean we've already
got to a position where this is becoming
quite a protracted
process so sometimes it's sensible to
rather than
having that separate meeting of the
panel
to invite the panel to to sit
as part of that hearing of the committee
so that they can hear the evidence then
and there's no need to then repeat
things that's a massive
for the council to do to determine um
in terms of officers to see what's most
appropriate in terms of process
depending on
um you know the specific circumstances
involved
so if the committee come to a decision
that
there's no further action that's the
decision that they make and there's no
further action
and it doesn't go any further if they
come to a decision that
there is an issue but that issue doesn't
warrant
dismissal then they can make the
decision at that point
what that sanction should be now there
is a right of appeal against that but
i'll come back to that later on
as i say if the committee determined
that um
that there should be a recommendation
for dismissal of that chief or statutory
officer
then assuming that the panel have
already sat as part of that committee
which as i say is is a more sensible or
resource-like way of doing things
then the independent person's panel will
go and write a report
giving their views and advice on the
recommendation
and the proposal
uh we'll also go through uh an executive
objections process
so that will uh very roughly
it goes to the the leader and
they consult with members of cabinet
as to whether there is any objection to
that proposal
if there are any objections within a set
period of time
then they are then put forward for
consideration by
the committee in terms of whether those
uh objections are um
well if they're well made and supported
if you like if they are then there'll be
a reconsideration as to the
recommendation that's been made
may then be that it does still go on um
but it may not so assuming that it still
goes
toward to to full council there is a
hearing of full council
the independent person's panel
will be there their report will have
been given to
full council as well um as will
the investigating report now now this
isn't
a rerun of of the the full hearing of
the evidence if you like it's a review
of
of what's been uh what's happened today
the decision that's been made
the advice that's been given by the
independent persons panel
etc and then council are required to
to make a decision uh whether they
agree with the recommendation to dismiss
as i say it would only go to full
council if it was a recommendation to
dismiss
and if they do then it's effective
if not they can substitute a decision
for something less
or they can send the matter back to
yourselves
to reconsider now i mentioned
rights of appeal if
the sanction if you like is
less than dismissal then there is a
right of appeal
now in the report there's an error for
which you know i i apologize
i think it's paragraph 3.2 um
it refers to any appeals going to
the council's committee that's currently
set up to hear
licensing appeals and other appeals um
that's not correct in the sense that the
council
i think what's been decided is that
given that these sorts of things are
hopefully
incredibly rare um you know it would be
appropriate to instead set up a an
appeal committee if and when that was
necessary and that can be done
relatively easily so it's not the case
that this will be added to
the appeal function will be added to
that
uh standing committee so that's just to
correct that error
and apologies on on that david could i
just say it's 3.6 sorry 3.6
excuse me i've only got one screen you
see and i don't have a printer
page 5.2 okay thank you thank you for
that
um so that is i know as i said it's
quite a complex
procedure it's all there in the report
um
so you know i agree i'd refer back to
that in any case
um hopefully um it won't become
something that happens frequently or or
you know at all if but it has to be
there by law so
there's a requirement that because it
needs to be there by law we need to
explain to you
um you know how it functions if it were
to
to be required now the committee is also
responsible you have seen in the terms
of reference
the the the committee is also
responsible for consideration
uh and determination of potential
settlements or severance of
chief officers employment with with the
council
again i do apologize
only because i thought we were coming to
the end but
the presentation is fine thank you madam
chairman
thank you for that councillor mason uh
david please continue
yes thank you chair so as i say the the
committee may also
consider um potential severance or
settlement of employment
contracts of chief officers
so that might arise during the
the process that we've just gone through
so at any point during that
process there may be proposals to
instead
settle rather than go through that full
process
and there are merits to that depending
on the circumstances
but of course if that was proposed there
would be detailed considerations to
whether that was an appropriate thing to
do
it might also be raised as a standalone
matter
might not have you know followed on from
a disciplinary issue or the like
so when in those circumstances what
would normally happen
is that say there was a proposed
settlement
the terms of a settlement will have been
discussed and negotiated by council
officers probably with external legal
support
and with the individual chief officer
who would probably also have their own
legal support and what would then be
coming forward to committee would be a
proposed set of
settlement terms to consider so
when considering those terms what the
commission committee needs to be asking
itself is
is a settlement in these terms in the
best interests of the council
is it an appropriate use of public funds
um
because as as members you have a
fiduciary duty to
taxpayers of course in the council's
area
and whether the the terms or the
settlement is in line with the
legislation that applies so we're
looking at things like the employment
rights act
there's various regulations particularly
local government early termination of
employment
regulations 2006 if you want to go and
have a look at those
the the title of those is that that is a
bit longer but i'll spare you from
reading you the whole title
um and um what those regulations say is
that the council can come to settlements
and severance agreements where to do so
is
in the interest of the efficient
exercise of
the council's functions um and to settle
potential
tribunal claims or that sort of thing so
it's quite there's a bit of scope there
there's also statutory guidance which
applies um
you may have seen in the news there's
some draft regulations
have been created which refer to exit
payments
in the public sector and what those
regulations
are proposing um subject to them being
uh amended i doubt there will be but
um is that there is a cap of uh 95 000
pounds on
any exit payment now that cap isn't
absolute
again these regulations that i'm
referring to are in draft form
presently um and there are exceptions to
it
what we what we have presently is
guidance
um from the secretary of state which
says that any
proposed settlement which is
of a value of a thousand hundred
thousand pounds or more
should be taken to full council rather
than it being dealt with by the
committee
so in those circumstances you might not
as a committee be
be dealing with it you might hear it in
the first instance and then refer it on
to full council that's not to say again
that
in all circumstances where a proposed
settlement is in excess of that figure
that you wouldn't uh be determining it
there are certain circumstances such as
where
you know it's a matter of urgency and
there are
due to perhaps sensitivities and
and other issues it needs to be dealt
with quickly so there can be a departure
from the guidance but
ordinarily not um so um
so the other thing i want to touch on i
mean of course dealing with these issues
and i is requires
you know the utmost confidence
confidentiality is
is very very important in relation to
dealing with these issues you're dealing
with personal data that you know
it's not just you know a council
function this is
about individuals and impact upon in
their lives
and so you need to be extremely careful
about the information that you will be
given
as part of this committee and are
required to keep
confidential now
there is something as you'll probably be
aware as members
and officers there is a statutory
indemnity
in place which says that
when you are undertaking your functions
in your roles as a member or an officer
you are protected from
liability if you like um for any
consequent claims that that might be
made
now that indemnity only applies where a
member or an officer is acting
and the wording from the legislation
it's from the eight it's from 1865 so
quite antiquated this is acting bonafide
in the interests
of the council which in essence means in
the council's
best interests genuinely in the
council's best interests
so if a member or an officer
were not considered to be acting in the
council's best interests
i.e disclosing confidential information
that they had received in consequence of
them being a member of this committee
then any subsequent loss that might be
uh occasion to the council
or to other individuals could
potentially be claimed back from
the individuals and they wouldn't be
indemnified so they would be personally
liable
so it's really important not just for
yourselves but also
for the proper functioning of the
council that you are fully aware of
the nature of where you have to or if
you ever have to deal with
a matter that comes through the
committee it's really really important
that the information is dealt with
confidentially
and as i say that's not just for the
council's benefit
because ultimately if for example
confidential information were disclosed
that was being considered as part of
that process
it might then be used as evidence by the
chief officer statutory officer
to support a claim against the council
in the long run to say look the council
hasn't acted fairly here
and this has caused me significant
damage to reputation or
or however so these things can come back
and
and and haunt the council if you like if
they're not dealt with properly
um and it's also for for the benefit of
the third party the chief office are
concerned because
as i say we're not dealing with hard
cold
functions of the council you know that
this is we're dealing with individuals
and
their lives as well so it's important to
respect that too
um so chair that's probably the
extent of what i wanted to to uh outline
um i apologize if i've gone on slightly
longer than
perhaps anticipated but i'm i'm very
happy to to answer any questions thank
you
thank you david um uh councilman mason
you have your hand raised
yes madam chairman it's councillor mrs
mason i prefer if you don't mind
apologies counsellor mrs mason thank you
um there's just two um things i'd like
some clarity on and one again it is
on protocol um
the monetary officer has mentioned them
in
1906 and confidential for that which i
quite understand but there is no
item six on the public published agenda
are we correct in doing so um that's
just a technical question that i'd like
reassurance on um perhaps
that one could be answered first okay i
i'm happy to address that or if angela
would like to address that
angela would you yeah yes absolutely
chairman so yes
um you're quite right counselor mrs
mason the um
urgent item is not on the agenda um
however under section now david would
correct me if i
forgot it's a hundred be
is it 100 b i have 600 b on second
one sorry is section 100 b sub section
4b
or of the local government act 19.
if it's um in the opinion of the
chairman that it is of a
urgent nature it can go on to the agenda
and i believe
chairman uh discussions have been had
with you with regards to this
agenda item and your agreement has been
sought
yes i can confirm that is the situation
thank you um thank you for clarifying
that um appreciate it
um and there's just one other thing with
the information you've given is is
uh very thorough very helpful it's also
very complex
it will be mirrored roughly on the
handout that we've
had published whilst i realized this
can't be done
now would it be possible to do a simple
flow chart
to so that's so that we can see
the logical progression because you've
said if the threshold
test is met it goes to a and if it's not
mess it goes to b
and i think um in some ways it would be
helpful to have a more visual
representation of that information
and then if we have any questions around
it
it would probably be answered almost by
the flowchart
and the other question that
um just for confirmation you've said all
the time the committee the committee
do i take it is the full committee we
don't break into subcommittees for this
i will answer that and we stay as a full
committee
that is my understanding would you like
me to address the
the other questions please okay so um
well it was the other question it was so
it's about
uh perhaps having a flowchart absolutely
i think a visual representation would
would definitely help
um i referred to the joint negotiating
committee they
that their handbook um that itself
sets out their suggested or required
process and it does indeed have a
flowchart so chair if i i'll get a hold
of a copy of that
and if i email it to yourself
and the officers uh for you to then
share around with members
and hopefully that will will assist um
so that's what i would propose in those
circumstances thank you david that would
be appreciated i'm sure that that'll be
very useful to be able to see that in in
that form
thank you councillor mrs mason um
councillor hoy
you have a question yeah thank you
chairman first of all i'd like to
apologize to you for my lateness
of them attending the meeting i'd and i
was on a phone call and didn't realize
the time
um and that my
i've obviously i've just found out about
the you've said there's going to be
something
private and confidential or exempt um an
item six which i wasn't aware of
so when you do that i'm gonna have to
move to another room
okay because i'm not in a i'm in a room
where i'm
next to the garden basically so i think
things could be overheard but
potentially
so i'd have to move and when you do that
we'll give you the opportunity
to have time to move thank you and um
when did you find out this urgent item
was being added to the agenda
i have been notified prior to the
meeting that this item would be added to
the agenda
and that is the correct procedure as i
understand it
today then before today
many days before today no i don't think
it's hard to say what day you were
advised
on chairman with respect
i don't think it's i personally don't
think it's actually relevant to give the
number of days and
i think we need to waste i don't believe
i need to waste time at this meeting
trying to remember exactly which day
i don't actually think that's important
i knew before the meeting
and it wasn't today it was either
yesterday or the day before or even the
day before that
so within three days right possibly
are you satisfied with that response
counsel ahoy
no but i'm happy to carry on with the
meeting thank you for your question
does anyone else have any questions for
uh david
in relation to the process
no well thank you david for um
for that presentation and uh thank you
for um
we will look forward to a flow chart to
give us a clearer understanding visually
of
how the process works and the steps
involved
members we now have come to the end of
the business that we can debate with
members um
of the public present via the live
stream
i will now move to uh
i will now move a recommendation that
under section
100 a 4
of the local government act 1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for the following item of business on
the grounds that it involves the likely
disclosure
i've got something strange come up on my
screen
not sure what that was i do apologize um
publicly excluded from the meeting for
the following item of business on the
grounds that it involves the likely
disclosure of exempt information
as defined in paragraph one of part one
of schedule 12a of the act
do i have a seconder
i'll second it uh thank you
um count the shaw thank you
sonia will now conduct a role of role of
call of names i have indicated to speak
you have just indicated to speak as i
read that out
sometimes councillor
um obviously you know my difficulty i'm
sure everyone here knows my difficulty
with exempt items generally
i have no doubt it is exempt because i'm
sure you will put something
through which wasn't but i'm not sure
how i can vote for something to be
exempt when i have no idea what it
is or what it's about that's all i'd
like um some
clarification on that from an officer if
possible please
chairman if i may um i do understand the
point that councillor hoy is making
um but it is an unusual situation on
this occasion
um um given um
the the remit of this committee all i
can say is a highly sensitive employment
matter
um that's all i can say at this stage
chairman
um um i i think uh members will have to
trust the officers on this one
thank you for that um they just say that
that obviously
you may have mentioned that earlier on
in the meeting which i was unable to
see that's quite helpful to know thank
you can i can i just say
it might be useful if uh angela repeats
what she said at the beginning about
indented
feet because councillor missed that
i take it i heard that from mr kittson
you understand the point about indemnity
but also given
the sensitive and confidential nato
nature we have asked members that they
need to
confirm that there is no other members
of how um your household or members of
public in the room with you
and that as i can see you have your
camera on throughout
the duration of that item of business
thank you
as i indicated earlier
i said i will be i would have to move
rooms when you said it would be going to
exempt i
do i am fully aware just for your
information i've also served on the um
personnel committee of the essex fire
authority and did have hearings there so
i'm aware of the
procedures thank you thank you
councillor hi thank you angela
so um sonia are you going to
um have a conductor roll call of names
i will thank you okay um so
so members if you can indicate if you'd
like a recorded vote
or if you're voting for against motion
or abstaining
uh counselling mrs belton no recorded
vote
for councillor fd
no we called he vote for the motion
no recorded vote and four councillor mrs
mason
thank you recorded vote for the motion
thank you
hanson newport owen
counselor mrs rowe no and four
thank you council mrs shaw
no and four councillors sparing
no and four
that's uh no recorded voting unanimously
approved chairman
thank you sonia um members that motion
is carried
foreign